it's a great time to be a sci-fi fan but
which films should you be watching
the past year gave us an onslaught of
mind-bending adventures
to choose from so without further ado
here are the best sci-fi movies of 2020.
canadian author filmmaker david
cronenberg has masterfully merged horror
and sci-fi themes on numerous occasions
throughout his career
and his son brandon cronenberg managed
the same feat with 2020's possessor
the film was met with rave reviews
earning widespread praise from the
critics
possessor is the story of tarzia played
by mandy's andrea rysborough an agent of
a corporation that uses brain implant
tech
to take control of people victims are
turned into unwilling hitmen
carrying out assassinations ordered by
the company's rich and powerful clients
tarzia is a natural at the job but she
gets more than she bargained for when
she inhabits the body of a man who
serves to violence eclipses even her own
the experienced agent loses control of
her host mind
and finds herself in danger of never
being able to escape it
leading to a thrilling and highly
abstract showdown between possessor and
host
[Music]
if any one movie was going to coax
people back into theaters in 2020 it was
tenet
christopher nolan's 11th feature was the
first blockbuster to play in theaters
during the coronavirus pandemic and it
certainly helped people take their minds
off covet 19 for a while
john david washington starts as a former
cia agent who's been recruited by a
secret organization
tenet which is working to prevent world
war iii he learns that weapons with
inverted entropy
manufactured in the future are somehow
making their way to the present day and
things get a whole lot weirder from
there
with help from robert pattinson's neil
washington's unnamed protagonist
learns that a russian oligarch has been
in contact with the future
our descendants have grown tired of the
ravaged world left of them and they
intend to invert the flow of time
in a last-ditch effort to change the
world it may not be christopher nolan's
finest film
but the slick action sequences and
impeccable performances make tennis one
of 2020s must-see
sci-fi films if an homage to ridley
scott's aliens said drawing the height
of the cold war
sounds like something you'd be
interested in you need to check out
sputnik
this slick russian creature feature was
forced to forego a theatrical release
because of the coronavirus pandemic
but it found lots of love on vod in its
native country
genre film distributor ifc midnight
secured the release rights for north
america
where critics have been raving about
igor abramenko's stylish debut
on paper abramenko's story is nothing
groundbreaking but he executes his scary
alien vision superbly
sputnik follows a cosmonaut who gets
quarantined after his vessel
malfunctions re-entering the earth's
atmosphere
what he doesn't know is that there's an
extraterrestrial parasite living inside
him
and when he sleeps it comes out to feed
the russian military manages to keep
this a secret
hoping to separate the creature from its
host and use it as a weapon of war
the cosmonauts only hope is a
sympathetic neurophysiologist who begins
masterminding his escape with suspense
to spare sputnik is a white knuckle
thrill ride that you can't afford to
miss
sci-fi comedy save yourselves is a story
of a young brooklyn couple
who decide to disconnect from the modern
world for a while they head out into
rural new york without their phones or
devices
while they're away aliens invade earth
and our heroes have absolutely no idea
as cities across america are reduced to
rubble our heroes busy themselves with
unbusying themselves
the city dwellers take advantage of the
nearby lake and surrounding nature
blissfully unaware that humankind is
under attack from fluffy but extremely
vicious extraterrestrials
gradually they come to the realization
that something isn't quite right
and their millennial morals are tested
when they discover a gun in the cabin's
basement
when push comes to shove they would
rather bear arms and be killed by a ball
of space fluff
writer directors alex huston fisher and
eleanor wilson didn't have a huge budget
so the majority of the action including
the levelling of yankee stadium
happens off screen this isn't a big vfx
heavy sci-fi film
but it really doesn't need to be sunita
mani and john paul reynolds are both
funny and convincing are sue and jack
and their vacation turned survival
mission is engaging enough that we don't
need to seal the peripheral destruction
we need to turn our phones back on
[Applause]
sorry making a smoothie listen it's
getting weird here in new york
bill and ted face the music was a tonic
for trying times in 2020.
alex winters bill s preston esquire and
keanu reeves ted theodore logan
returned to the big screen for a belated
third adventure in late summer
though the coronavirus pandemic meant it
had an unusual theatrical release
box office returns were a predictably
dire 3.3 million dollars
but bill and ted face the music was also
released on pvod
and deadline sources suggest it made
around 10 times that amount via
streaming in the same period
the simultaneous release meant critics
nationwide got to see the movie
and the majority of them deemed it most
excellent our titular besties are now
middle-aged fathers
as bill and ted go forward in time in
search of their future selves
their daughters go in the opposite
direction recruiting iconic musicians
for the band that will help their dads
finally perform their universe
saving song reeves and winter slip back
into their roles with ease
and their on-screen daughters are just
as watchable variety called the film a
blissed-out air balloon of nostalgia in
a glowing review
while the hollywood reporter called it
quote almost exactly as good as its two
big screen predecessors
archive may not win any awards for
originality but as the hollywood
reporter puts it
the directorial debut of concept artist
gavin rothery is a quote sleek and
satisfying riff on familiar sci-fi
themes
rothery's film plays like a mashup of ex
machina and black mirror
and takes place in 2038 when a widowed
roboticist named george almore is on the
verge of a groundbreaking advancement
almor works for a mega corporation that
specializes in artificial intelligence
when we meet him his human equivalent
prototype is just about ready
but this isn't just a replication of any
old human the savvy scientist has
recreated his deceased wife
in robot ai form behind the backs of his
bosses the trouble is his creation ends
up being a little too real
we're not going to spoil it here but
trust us when we say the archive
contains one of the best movie twists
of 2020 sci-fi or otherwise
sci-fi adventure love and monsters
proved popular when it was released on
pvod in october 2020
and the critics loved it too this
dystopian teen film takes place some
seven years after mankind
turned its nukes on a planet-killing
asteroid that was on a collision course
with earth
they destroyed their intended target but
nobody was quite prepared for the brutal
aftermath the fallout caused all
cold-blooded animals to mutate into huge
terrifying creatures
former maze runner star dylan o'brien
leaves the line as one of a number of
survivors
living in an underground bunker the film
was lauded as an imaginative
post-apocalyptic coming-of-age film
by the new york times while variety
called it a quote
definitely lightweight throwback to the
teen action adventures of the 80s and
90s
marvel fans will recognize some familiar
faces here joel's girlfriend amy is
played by iron fist star jessica henwick
michael rooker of guardians of the
galaxy and ariana greenblatt from
avengers infinity war
also make appearances in the film
spontaneous was one of the most
critically acclaimed movies of 2020
scoring a near perfect 98 on rotten
tomatoes
in brian duffield's directorial debut
students at covington high school have
started to inexplicably explode at
random intervals
sowing dread and anxiety among their
surviving classmates
the film's quarantined scenes drew
inevitable comparisons to the
coronavirus pandemic but spontaneous was
done and dusted before covid19 was a
thing
according to deathfield his goal was to
make a movie that captured what it meant
to be a kid
at that moment in time he said in his
looper exclusive interview
i'm very liberal and for me the movie
feels like a very real thing that kids
are dealing with right now
when we shot the movie there were these
things happening in the world where it
really felt like kids were being like we
need someone to help us
and it was really falling on deaf ears
the writer director also revealed that
80's classic heathers and the films of
john hughes were among his many
inspirations
fifty shades of greystar jamie dornan
and avengers actor anthony mackie
play a pair of paramedics in synchronic
a new orleans set sci-fi that made a big
impression when it premiered at the
toronto international film festival
directed by justin benson and aaron
morehead synchronic follows dennis and
steve as they're called to a series of
strange and gruesome incidents
the pair believes that a new designer
drug called synchronic is to blame for
it all
but when dennis's daughter seriously
goes missing it's up to steve to
investigate further
he soon discovers that synchronic is
more than meets the eye these mysterious
pills allow the user to travel through
time
one of the many criticisms leveled at
the fifty shades franchise was that the
coast stars had zero chemistry
but that certainly isn't a problem here
dornan and mackie sold their
relationship
well delivering believable performances
as two best friends going through
personal ruts
synchronic gets pretty trippy but the
two leads keep us invested in their
modern day problems
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite new movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one